hi in this video we are going to be
talking about the console what it is
where you can find it and what you use
it for now the console is very commonly
used to display system administrative
messages your browser has a console your
computer has a console once you become
more familiar with it you'll find it to
be a really powerful and effective tool
in JavaScript the console is used as a
great tool for debugging and finding out
where in your code there's a problem one
of the most important words you're going
to need to remember is console dot log
now console is the thing that shows a
text dot log means vloggity are right in
here then there are some parentheses and
you can write whatever you want now the
process of doing this it can be put
anywhere in the lines of code just like
in the last video we go down
sequentially you can put some kind of
statements that say you know if this
doesn't work console.log this is broken
on line 43 or whatever you need to do to
help yourself figure out what the
problem is and where it's happening
alright what you see here is the Chrome
browser with the chrome console the
console can also be up on the side but
we're gonna keep it down below for now
you're probably also seeing this console
dot log we are going to console log a
string a string is inside quotes or
single quotes like this lets console
free code and rocks now if we run this
code right here now here it's false
that's what it's returning to this but
down here in the console you see free
code camp rocks awesome right now we can
also console a number like 1024 and
there it is and we can also console a
boolean which is a true or false
statement I think you do console.log
true and it's gonna say true if we try
and say a word like words and
console.log that it's nothing's gonna
happen that doesn't recognize words
because it doesn't know if it's a string
or what but once you put it inside of
some of these guys then it
we're talking about you can also combine
things so today I want to say
console.log Breanna is and then true
we'll see what happens there we get
Breanna is true you can see the color
differentiation here if your screens big
enough if not it just as Breanna is and
then true is in blue because that's a
boolean as opposed to the string you can
use this in a bunch of different ways
but this is what console really looks
like